hey this is preshtalwalker
in the first quadrant graph the lines y
is equal to 3x and y is equal to x
if y is equal to kx is the angle
bisector of the angle between these two
lines what is the value of k equal to
this problem is from the 2021
fall amc 12a
which is a qualifying test for the
mathematical olympiad competition in
america
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
there are many ways to solve this
problem i will present a solution that
involves geometry
first let's graph the line x is equal to
one which will intersect all three of
these lines
we'll label the first point as a this
will be one comma one the second point
as b this will be one comma k
and the third point as c
this will be one comma three
label the origin as o and focus on
triangle oac
we can use the distance formula to
calculate the length of o a
it'll be equal to the square root of two
we can also calculate the length of oc
this will be equal to the square root of
10.
then bc is equal to 3 minus k
and a b is equal to k minus 1.
let's label these line segments
we now know that the line ob is the
angle bisector of angle c o a
and thus we can use the angle bisector
theorem
this implies that oc over bc is equal to
oa over a b
we can substitute these values in
now we just have to simplify this
equation and solve for k
we will cross multiply then we'll divide
both sides by the square root of two
and then we will group like terms
from here we will divide both sides by
the square root of five plus one
just for fun we will rationalize this
denominator by multiplying the numerator
and denominator by the square root of
five minus one
we'll simplify this equation and we get
that k is equal to one plus the square
root of five all over two
and that's approximately equal to 1.618
which is equal to the golden ratio
what a golden answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you